hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast quantitation and
profiling metabolomics and translation
to clinical analysis presented by dr.
Timothy Garrett associate professor
University of Florida I'm Alexis Krause
of Blackbirds and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by Agilent Agilent is a leader and life
sciences diagnostics and applied
chemical markets the company provides
laboratories worldwide with instruments
services consumables applications and
expertise enabling customers to gain the
insights they seek agilent's expertise
and trusted collaboration
give them the highest confidence in our
solutions for more information on our
sponsor please visit WWE
what skit started before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation you do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button once as
many of your questions is we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left ear screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Timothy Garrett dr.
Garrett received his undergraduate
degree from the University of Georgia in
chemistry graduating and graduating
summa [ __ ] laude with highest honors in
1999 as an undergraduate he worked in
the lab of dr. John
the name sir on the characterization of
bacterial proteins using the multi-tow
completing an undergraduate honors
thesis entitled improve methods for on
probe cleanup of on purified poaching
samples for multi time-of-flight mass
spectrometry he received his PhD in 2006
from the University of Florida working
under the direction of dr. Richard a
Yost as a graduate student he developed
the first imaging mass spectrometry
based on ion trap instrumentation
through a partnership with thermo and
studied the disposition of phospholipids
in brain tissue he is currently an
associate professor and the Department
of Pathology where he is also the
director of high-throughput metabolomics
for the southeast Center for integrated
metabolomics the conducts research in
the application of metabolomics to
disease diagnosis and clinical
Diagnostics professor garrett is the
author of over 60 publications and is an
editorial board for clinical mass
spectrometry his current interests are
in the application of direct tissue
analysis approaches as well as the use
of high resolution mass spectrometry and
metabolomics and routine Diagnostics dr.
Garrett you may now begin your
presentation great thank you very much
for that wonderful introduction and
thank you for this opportunity today to
talk about some of the work that we do
in our in my lab and some of the work
that we're hopefully trying to do in
clinical Diagnostics to sort of bring
the next generation of Diagnostics to
our clinic a lot so today I'm going to
talk about several points I'm going to
talk about quantitative and several
omics I'm going to talk about
traditional quantitation aspects that
are related to currently how we do most
quantitation I'm gonna talk about where
we can be going in the future in this in
this approach and then I'm going to talk
about primarily the role of high
resolution mass spectrometry as it plays
in quantitative aspects here and then a
key part of that is understanding
isotope approaches that may enable
different and multiple analyte analyses
within a single run so if we look at the
traditional quantitative mass
spectrometry that's done it's touch
primarily liquid chromatography the LC
an MSM is or tandem mass spectrometry
and so on and in this case every sample
gets an internal standard or a reference
standard that helps you quantitate
typically it's a stable isotope version
of that compound for example tryptophan
d3 japonica quantified tryptophan and in
general carbon is typically a better
isotope than deuterium because we don't
have any retention time shifts that
might occur in a chromatographic Bronwen
deuterium is involved but if the term is
used a trip to aid a d3 that is usually
preferred over in more multiple DS in in
a sample and so each metabolite is also
externally calibrated and recovering the
reference range of interests and that
reference range in a clinical setting is
defined by the ranges in which might be
normal abnormal or or out of the range
of quantitation and so one example would
be say 10 nanograms per mil to 10,000
nanograms per mil and each one of these
has a defined llq or lower limit of
quantitation LOD lower limit of
detection and a dynamic range that
covers how linear that the coverage
would be innocent minutes in assembled
and each metabolite has a separate curve
and separate internal standard and
separate quantified sample for every
every metabolite so that's if you have
50 analytes you want to quantify you two
people that have 50 calibration curves
to quantify each one and the key here to
point out is that we're measuring the
ratio of the metabolite to the internal
standard and that's important because it
helps to avoid iron suppression and it
helps to enable you to quantify in
multiple kinds of samples where the iron
suppression may be different across
those different segments so why we want
to do HPLC or LC followed by tandem mass
spectrometry well the primary reason is
it helps us with the three essence in
performance and those our sensitivity we
have a really broad range from picomolar
to micromolar range and even lower than
people molar range it's very selective
we have three ways to select an ion we
have
tenshun time from chromatography we have
the last two charge value and we have
the fragment ions or a product dies
produced during that ms/ms event and the
master charge value is one I'm gonna
focus it on a lot today because it
involves the use of high resolution and
high mass accuracy instrumentation to
help push the boundaries of where we can
measure within a single sample and then
the last s is speed mass spectrometry
methods can be very fast they can be
less than 30 seconds depending on how
many analytes you want to measure and so
it enables high Cupit analyses of
multiple of thousands of samples in a
week or a month depending on the the
throughput of meat so if you sort of
look at this in in a chromatic in a
figure you can see that in
chromatographic space we can separate it
a long time while in that space we sub
through the items and then the third
third window is ms EMA so a single line
produces us a specific fragment that we
may monitor to isolate that so it allows
us to be highly selective in a very
complex matrix that would be in plasma
or urine or serum one that might be
measured in a clinical Center and this
harkens back to the old to a figure that
was produced several years ago about the
idea of combined techniques in mass
spectrometry and how those combined
techniques can enable improved
measurement and so this this figure is
an example of where you have signal that
decays over time with the number of that
not over time with the number of stages
of analysis and you also have a chemical
noise that reduces over time over the
number of analyses but combined together
those and produce a higher
signal-to-noise because then we reduce
the noise at a faster rate than reduce
the signal and this or signal-to-noise
is what we measure in mass spectrometry
and that and so by doing two techniques
say LC followed by mass spectrometry we
get a gain in signal-to-noise and then
three techniques we get a subsequent
gain in that signal to noise and so it
allows us to have complimentary set
selectivity and so in most cases you're
doing LC ms/ms but you can do LC ms/ms
ms or LC ion mobility
spectrometry which would be as a third
complementary technique in separation
and one example of where quantitation is
done is with a triple quad and so what
I'm showing here is an example of a
schematic of a triple quad where we have
three quadruples quadruple 1 2 & 3 and
most in almost all cases cluttered
particle 2 is held at a constant value
just allowing gas to be introduced to
cause fragmentation so in this example Q
1 is held at a specific ion to say let's
say tryptophan is isolated it's
fragmented in Q 2 and then in q3 you can
scan to find all of all those product
ions to get all the different different
masses you might have interest in a
quantitative performance you would
select only one or maybe two of those
analytes of those product ions and q3 as
a way to select a single reaction or
selected reaction monitoring when you're
selecting more than one you might be
called might call it multiple reaction
management and an example of this is a
tryptophan as a as I use across a lot of
odd figures here tryptophan has a in
this case on them on a low-resolution
low mass accuracy is forming a
quadrupole would have a measure s of 205
point one we would isolate that ion and
get a product I spectrum on the second
figures below showing two primary
product product times one is a loss of
two alhasan mean to produce 188 and the
other one is 146 and this points out a
key part of selective reaction and that
means more selecting than say a loss of
the water or ammonia because those I
those losses are less indicative of a of
a compound or a metabolite so the ion at
146 would be a much more reliable SRM
ion to monitor to ensure we measure
tryptophan in a more precise way and one
thing to note here is in hotend the
figure on top there's a lot of noise in
the measurement so it appears that we
don't detect our iron very well but in
the bottom part you see how clearly
clear the noise is this is the
reflection of multiple stages of
analysis
reducing the noise to enhance the signal
toys to noise measurement and if we add
chromatography in this case we can
separate say two other compounds and
which have a lights related to
tryptophan one is Chimeran II which is a
downstream product of tryptophan through
the ideal metabolism and is often
measured as a way to monitor the immune
system and so we have a separation
within that that it alludes at an
earlier time the tryptophan and the
later one is a is a drug that has been
studied with you alter the immune system
called one methyl tryptophan or one MT
and so in this case if you can monitor
this drug a 1nt and then two metabolites
that might be altered by that drug
performance to get a general idea of how
the body is reacting in the in that
given instance so if we look at a
different example one that is a smaller
or more maybe more polar analyte
metformin is a very polar probably mean
drug it's using the treatment of type 2
diabetes there's also been some recent
reports evaluating it as a longevity
drug although that that's still under
works and so in our case we wanted to
look at the evaluation of metformin in
relation to a lupus or a autoimmune
disorder that was studied to see whether
or not we could quantify values and
stored samples to then develop a future
project to evaluate the use of metformin
in larger clinical trials and so in this
case we developed a standard LC ms/ms
method and in this in our setting we use
a pillock which is hydrophilic
interaction liquid chromatography as a
improved way to do separation because it
enables the retention of more polar
analytes rather than reverse phase
chromatography and say we took 20
microliters of a patient sample and
added a cedar nitro containing on the
gas 'add and i also contained the
internal standard in this case we're
using a d6 metformin the one that was
only available for this setting and then
we
we mixed it we centrifuged it and then
transferred only the super light so you
can see it's a very dilute process
adding 500 microliters to only 20
microliters of patience and then only
injecting 2 to 5 microliters for
analysis this is gone 350 marketing
years of it and if we look at a simple
example with 10 nanograms per mil of LC
ms/ms method on a on a triple quad you
can see the separation is where the
retention is fairly good for the
satellite for hillock and with a mobile
things described as above but the point
also because this is an LC ms/ms QQQ run
can we possibly use this as a high
resolution approach to modern monitors
metformin because part of the goal will
need to also monitor other analytes
present in a sample rather than just the
drug of interest but other metabolites
that may be affected or may help us
understand the phenotypes of an
individual taking this drug and and so
you can sort of see here that that's the
calibration curve that looks fairly
linear in this case and so now switching
to high resolution we also decided flows
so now we're throwing two things at it a
low slow flow separation approach using
a different source and the same
separation can character resistance it's
about 30,000 mass resolving power and
collecting a wider mass range of say 70
to hunt 2,000 and positive ion but only
and this would allow us to get the
endogenous metabolites but also target
the net flow on the compound of interest
and this is a that translated example
running at 1 micrometer per minute and
this is a tendon nanogram per mil
metformin separated if about a minute
only on this we get it in hillock and
low flow rate you get a little bit less
retention than you would at higher flow
rates and a larger bore column but it
still enable us to measure this compound
of interest and you can see the product
dying spectrum below measure down to the
mass accuracy of less than 5 parts per
million and getting product down spectra
that allows us to validate the
is the right kind of engines if you look
very close down sorry that excuse me
we'll go back to that slide before that
wasn't the product guide and the point
I'm trying to point out there this is
the background in a high-resolution scan
and the next slide this is where
metformin is so it's really down around
10% of the signal and it's in what you
consider the noise but of a typical mass
spectrum but now we have very clearly
isolating the compound using high
resolution and high mass accuracy and
then if we look at a calibration plot we
have a triple quad on the right
calibration and then high resolution
quantitation on the left looking at a
very similar performance maybe it a
little bit higher error on the higher
end of measurement but the key is really
knowing how well nothing's perform
against each other and so if we look at
the quantified performance between the
two methods and there's only high
resolution no tandem mass spectrometry
so just using the mass accuracy of the
instrument and the resolution of the
instruments isolate the aisle and so in
this case we get almost a less than five
percent error in most cases and when we
don't measure we don't measure it in
both methods which is reliable and then
maybe it has is six percent and the this
this quick patient sample and then the
QC of 500 looks very reproducible across
both methods and so what this tells us
is that we can run a very similar
quantitative performance on both types
of instruments for a target compound
with the brain wide range of interest
and this allows us to to then do
possible future studies that enable us
to do a endogenous quantitation of
analytes of interest beyond just the one
targeted to this trade compound so so
that leads us to what we want to do in
the future and so in traditional
untargeted whatever illness which is
what I do a majority of my work in
you're typically doing an experiment
without really knowing what the
significant features are because that's
the point we're trying to develop new
significant compounds
well nude missin if they get metabolites
related to Z versus in targeted
quantitation where we we would look for
targets of interest and then try to see
if those are significant between the
samples and in a in a combined workflow
we would run maybe untargeted first and
then targeted quantitation second on a
set of compounds of interest so we're
then doing two different experiments on
the same set of samples which would use
more samples or use more material and
use more instrument time and then in
some ways and I'll show you an example
later that sometimes target image of
elements is chosen first because results
are easier to interpret and then that's
just part of the field at Mattel a woman
says it grows and as we make the title
it's easier to understand but a sort of
goal is really to be able to do combined
connotation in a single injection with
high resolution mass spectrometry and
getting an internal standard for each
compound in the next few slides I hope
to show you what that really means and
so really what sort of a background it's
kind of just show you what this
conceptually means the only thing that
we're really changing of is mass
spectrometer and that's really the
improvement of how we measure the
compounds of interest so really just
measuring the mass in a more precise and
a more highly resolved way so you can
keep the same chromatography the same
column in the same flow rate without any
things that are changing the only other
an additive benefits are here described
below without mass accuracy and
combining that with resolution and of
course you can add ms/ms and so you're
getting mass accuracy and high
resolution in and the sanest mode is low
if you look at just a specific specific
example and most of our work is done on
a time of flight range but this just
shows you the types of insurance in
instruments that would would be
available for this kind of work a
quadrupole which is what we did are
starting over work on doing ms/ms
or plating a compounded interest yeah a
fairly low resolution you can't tell
differences in this figure and then when
you increase the resolution you're gonna
see more of the picture right and FTMs
is the highest resolution available on
the market but you typically would need
much more expensive instrumentation to
do that work
and enable that that clear separation
but with the time of flight or with a
other kind of measurement measurements
from it you get an improved measure of
that compound and it just well ideally
it's really just improves clarity of the
measurement and so this is really an
example of looking at one compound
valine a common amino acid that might be
detected in the cell but you can look at
the carbon-12 ion of interest first to
the carbon 13 90 meters and we keep our
here is you can measure the abundance of
both and so measuring the abundance of
the carbon 13 allows us to know how many
carbons are present in that compound and
so in this case our measured abundance
of the carbon 13 nice and super valine
is about 5.4 percent and the actual
abundance is 5.5 percent so we could get
a very good estimation of the number of
carbons within this compound if we have
enough resolution to separate it out the
isotopes out from the carbon-12 license
but if we look even closer there's more
information there depending on the
resolution that might be available or
how high pi you can measure you can even
separate carbon 13 from nitrogen 15
isotopes to help even it help them
better inform a prediction so this is
just one of the additive benefits of
high resolution mass spectrometry that
might enable you to as an improved
measured mass and improve measuring your
compounds of interest so now let's take
a different example where I've talked a
lot about tryptophan I've been studying
tryptophan for a while in terms of the
metabolic pathways of tryptophan for
initially with organ transplantation and
initially with just looking at
tryptophan defining as a measure of
whether or not we can use that ratio to
help predict organ transplantation
whether would would continue in a
successful route or whether we'd have to
bring the patient back in to understand
whether or not they're rejecting that
organ and in general that that is a
fairly good measure in that in that
setting to be able to monitor how well
the immune system is working and whether
or not your inactivated immune system or
whether or not your
you're working in a normal immune system
environment but it ideally tryptophan
has other metabolites of keen interests
one serotonin is another one of interest
as well as melatonin both of those are
neurotransmitters that do have different
neurological States typically melatonin
is associated with sleep and serotonin
is associated with an overall feeling of
a joy or feeling in a fairly good mood
and you have other downstream products
that are part of the kymia ranek pathway
that might have other neurological
effects that would be important to
measure and so it would be very
important for us to be able to measure
as many tryptophan metabolites as
possible so we can not only measure
immune system but also measure the
neurotransmission parts that that
tryptophan is related to and one thing
that I haven't pointed out yet but
tryptophan is an essential amino acid so
it's something that we do need to get in
our diet to be able to provide the
tryptophan related pathways and ensure
that we're getting the right metabolites
immersed in our button and this is an
example as say looking at tryptophan
looking at the separation of tryptophan
at one specific mass resolving power and
this is tryptophan target compound at
205 109 seven and then we in this case
we had more than one internal standard
we had one at 208 which is a d3
deuterium labeled and then we have a
carbon 13 level at 216 and so with this
we get accuracy you get the isotopic in
that envelope but we can also get some
other features if we do say I isolate
both of those ions or all of those ions
of interest and this is an example of
just sort of how high resolution can be
used as a way as a further separation so
in a typical triple quad kind of way you
might isolate each one of the of the
target compounds of interest so I'd
isolate tryptophan separately then
isolate what its internal standard
separately and I'd measure those
transitions which is a great way to do
the experiment but with high resolution
we could possibly isolate a wider range
of those masses and include all the
masses of interest in a single scan and
so in this case I show you and what that
might look like for tryptophan coloring
the ones related
to each other together and so we have a
and you can sort of see how well those
separate out and how well the MS Emma
still performs where we might isolate
say a ten am you wide window and this is
collecting all those product ions and
using the product ions from that as a
way to qualify you can might might see
how well this works say for ms/ms
in this case is ms/ms of each one of
those compounds so it shows very nice
performance along with its internal
standard and in this case we had an
internal standard for every compound and
that very good mass very good signal to
noise for a good quantitation vision but
now you can look at just the mass
accuracy and that's just using the full
scan ms no ms/ms
with a 5 ppm si cursory window so this
is still targeted but it's targeted
using the mass accuracy of yours from it
as the as the selection window and you
can see we still get very good signal to
noise in most chases maybe an antenna
for Anthony like acid which could be a
tramatic acid is as the internal
standard but in most cases we get very
clean chromatographic performance so
this is a method that we now apply we
use this quantified method for many
different studies in one study I'll show
you as a highlight is tryptophan
metabolism so using an understanding of
what our gut and the role of our gut is
in doing tryptophan and metabolizing
tryptophan within the body and so this
is a collaboration with the University
of Florida professor dr. Gary Wayne an
infectious disease a little medicine our
main goal here is to look at germ-free
mice so those are mice without any
microbes in their gut look at a set of
mice that have a single type of microbe
in their debt and that would be a mono
associated a coli and then those that
have a tryptophan asa cleanin or no
tryptophan is present or no species of
presents to degrade tryptophan so we can
get an understanding of that and for now
I'm really just going to show you the
germ-free results so because we can want
it as we're still building this project
and our main goal and one of our main
goals is really to focus on
understanding the role
specific nutrient in this case
tryptophan on the role it plays in gut
and the gut brain axis and how that may
relate to how we would improve our
neurotransmission or improve different
for different parts of the tryptophan
metabolism within our system and if I
look at it if we look at a single
example this is looking at germ-free
mice and looking at or germ-free rats
excuse me
with a clear separation on the left if
you're not familiar with metabolomics of
statistical analysis this is principal
components analysis or PCA and the PCA
plot on your left shows the separation
of control and tryptophan supplemented
rats from those that are deficient where
we get a very clean separation between
the deficiency and those that had either
the normal amount of trips better of a
higher amount of tryptophan and then the
depleted ones are in green and and
really basically what that shows you is
that when you deplete an essential
nutrient you're gonna have a very
drastic effect on the on the system
because that your body does not have
that system or does not have that
nutrient to make the key metabolites of
interest if we look on the right this is
a heat heat map or a clustering map
showing the top 25 metabolites that are
present and this is in this sample and
in this case this is serum isolated
through protein precipitation where we
would remove all the protein isolate
only the metabolites and then inject the
small amount this would be injecting
about five microliters of a sample into
onto the chromatography system and in
this setting we're using reverse phase
chromatography as the separation and so
what we when we look at a heat map we
can get a better idea that we do
separate out some metabolites that are
key in the tryptophan sub supplemented
and those that are normal and some of
those would be of course serotonin which
is at the bottom Ono's anther and gasses
at the bottom it's and tryptophan I'll
be obviously when you're increasing
tryptophan you have some
but another key metabolite in this case
is serotonin that's highly increased in
those that are supplemented with
tryptophan if you look at the pathways
that might be highlighted in this case
you can sort of see that where we have
tryptophan is a key nutrient leading to
to serotonin and the settles that are
toning and down that trig
neurotransmitter pathway versus also
down some the nicotinamide or
niacinamide pathway leading to nad and
NADP it so in a summary of the
tryptophan approach we only use this
method all the time we quantify methods
of high resolution only and get all the
other metabolites of interest and if you
saw in that heat map there is more
metabolites obviously then we quantify
we only quantified about six in that
measurement and so ideally we'd like to
measure more than that maybe five
hundred to a thousand different
metabolites so we can get a better
quantitative performance to know how
much is there versus how much is missing
or how much is indifferent in that case
how much is deficient so one of those
approaches that we're looking at is
using isotope labeling approaches that
grow cells and grow cells with a high
amount of carbon 13 in this case we're
using 95% carbon 13 and a technique
called high stop isotope ratio outlier
analysis or aroma and this is in a
collaboration with with the rosette and
if we look at what's here in a typical
or on the left side you have a carbon-12
side this would be a carbon-12
sorry carbon 13 glucose but at 5%
labeled and that would produce a
descending isotope pattern that
increases the carbon 13 abundance by a
significant amount so we can measure
better better when we combine both of
these together with a 95% carbon 13 and
the 5% carbon 13 level we get this
pattern that produces a but a u-shape
pattern that produces a non-natural
isotope effect and so on the right side
is the non natural aspects where we have
an M minus 1 and minus 2 that would not
be normally present in in the giving
systems
so what I sort of tell people is it
represents the DNA of a metabolite
because now we're producing things that
are not natively present and you can
easily capture and identify metabolites
that are
aissatou isotopically labeled to glucose
in a given system and they match those
with a carbon-12 side as a way to
measure the a single metabolite was both
an internal standard on the right and
the the natural abundance on the left we
accomplished this by using the East as a
primary test case because it's a little
bit less expensive to use and it's
fairly easy to grow and a lot of
conditions that enable us to produce it
in a high high quantities which is what
we would need and so in this case we
extract only the small molecules from
the east and we standardize everything
to that extract and we're using the
yeast extract essentially as the
internal standard it's 95 percent
labeled and in it allow us to do both
normalization and quantitation in the
same run this is an example of what it
would look like so in this case we have
the natural abundance of tryptophan
where they have normal carbon-13
abundance on the left with carbon-12 and
carbon-13 and on the right side we have
fully labeled tryptophan that's that
negative isotope pattern producing that
that that very distinguishable feature
that allows us to identify it in a
complex matrix and in this case we're
pretty we also can then calculate the
exact number of carbons so for an
unknown an unknown metabolite that we
might not have identified through the
various means we can use the carbon-12
side and the carbon Foley carbon labeled
13 side as a second as a third measure
because we still get the isotope of a
the single license of carbon 13 level is
one measure but it's a third way to
confirm the number of carbons that are
in a specific unknown which allows us to
then do better formula prediction and so
this is an example of what it might look
like when you're using a low versus a
high concentration of a target compound
in this case it's history it's looking
at a higher amount where we have we
spiked it in a bomb or internal standard
in this case it's the highest level it's
62 microgram
four mill verses at the lower level and
you can see that performance the same
normal performance you would get with a
quantitative run keeping your internal
standard constant and we still have the
same preserve isotope pattern for
everything and if we look at the
linearity I like reduced but in
something like this it follows the same
lines that you saw earlier in the slide
where a triple quad quantitation with an
internal standard the gold standard of
what we would measure anything against
versus what I showed the tryptophan high
resolution ms or high resolution ms/ms
quantization very linear calibration
curves and in very very strong
sensitivity you can even do both reverse
phase and buck approaches to separate
and quantify it the same compound name
is face I'm showing prolene which is
retained longer on a hillock approach
with a little bit higher RS even we
might get on a reverse phase approach
but those things can be measured and
optimized depending on your system and
in biological samples you can do the
same thing that was just looking at
bunch of standards and here you can see
this just shows what it would look like
with tryptophan again and again that
change of response that you might see
and then again showing another another
internal another amino acid not just one
thing but other amino acids are of
course quantified well within the system
and those this is looking at from unique
across multiple runs and how we might
look at the reproducibility on a given
day or multiple or giving and so in the
end what we're still working on this
method we've been able to quantify most
of the amino acids using this approach
and expanding out to other compounds of
interest as a secondary validation and
so recovery is very good with this is
within plasma samples of course we run a
very rigid rigid validation and quality
control with each run very low variance
stability of the yeast is is so far very
stable so it allows us to store it for
quite a bit at times for measurement and
again we're men
the natural and endogenous natural
abundance against an internal standard
and and in general we have what we
should have a nice texture act is
somewhere on 500 different metabolites
so we have the ability to expand it well
beyond what we might measure and this
was only doing high-resolution no ms/ms
no further quantitation but where is
still validating where you might need
MSM is where you might need only high
resolution as a key future component of
doing quantitative analyses with this
kind of approach and so ideally what
we'd like to do is be able to provide a
quantitative performance on this
platform using that all of those key
targeted compounds that are in there but
we haven't lost our ability to look at
unknown metabolites that might show up
in unique samples so we can still use
data mining and tools that you might use
for that such as open source tools like
MZ mine or other tools that you might
use to do statistical analyses you can
look at many different ways to identify
those unknowns to help fill in the
metabolomic space and you can also look
at what what future transmite beats by
capturing a lot of different unknowns in
a single run and sometimes it's easier
to just look at the targeted analysis
and and gather say quantify a small set
of targeted compounds and only look at
those that are known because it is in
general it is it is an easier way to
provide results to individuals so why do
we want to still do and targeted and
here is sort of an example of what I
like to show and that is is that we have
a global metabolomic round on the left
and this is looking at prostate cancer
and looking at PCA say 2,000 different
compounds versus on the right where
you're looking at pca set around 50
different analytes so in individually
the analytes are there are significant
metabolites within the targeted
quantitative set but overall when you
look at them as a group they don't
perform in terms of being able to
separate the manifestations of a
clinical disorder in this case this
clinical is sort disorder
be not just prostate cancer which would
be here in the green but also
prostatitis or benign prostatic
hyperplasia BPH and ideally a clinical a
measuring clinical samples should
measure the clinical scope or clinical
manifestations of a disorder not just
between cancer but between other
disorders of hyper presence so you have
a a test that might improve the
quantitative performance and so if we
use a profiling approach we can capture
more metabolites and get a better idea
of those that might might separate our
disorders of interest rather than just
looking at a smaller quantitative set
and this just shows you that in the same
example so some things to summarize
there are still no sort of rules that
exist for how accurate you need to be
and so those kinds of questions need to
be validated so do you need to have 5
ppm every time or is 30 ppm s accuracy
sufficient in some cases the only way to
test that would be to look at how in
reducing your accuracy and how well your
method still performs again the same
goes for mass resolution and that's of
course instrument dependent and
metabolite dependent but you need to
know when your method may not work
depending on when the resolution falls
apart or when the isobaric compounds are
interfering it and don't allow you to do
this they don't allow you to do very
much separation and then the dynamic
range is a key part typically you have
shorter dynamic range with high
resolution mass spectrometry than you do
with a triple one and so you have to
take that into account with developing a
method that your your order your
measurement range needs to account the
accounted for the instrument in which
you use to do that quantitation
and so with that thank you for your time
and listening to this presentation and I
also will take any questions that you
might have
Thank You dr. Kerry for your informative
presentation we want to start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen
Emel answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is why did you employ
high resolution mass spectrometry for
quantitation and metabolomics since it
is usually performed by a triple
quadrupole well in our case using high
resolution was a key part to help
understand the future of what we want to
measure and so our one of our goals is
to be able to use a single platform to
do many different kinds of measurement
rather than having to expand a new
instrument every time we need to do a
different measurement so in this case
using high resolution enabled us to
separate out and well at least the ones
I showed separate out metabolites of
interest using only high resolution and
mass accuracy and get similar
performance that you might get with a
triple quad as well as being able to
improve the identification of other
species within the sample within a set
that you may not have thought about
measuring or may not know about
measuring so really in this case it's
one that we really want to expand the
role that high resolution might play in
the clinical setting knowing that most
clinical labs and most clinical research
for quantitation is done on a triple
plot so it is an uphill battle to try to
do that but I think it in with the right
examples I think hopefully we can be
shown that it has the capability to do
it right and precisely our next question
is why did you only show no assets for
your quantitation with labeled yeast
extract so so far the amino acids is
just what we focused on as a way to do
say inter lab studies and it's an it's a
good start to be able to do it because
if you can't quantify the amino acids
within a within a run and within a
metabolomic run then you probably won't
be able to do other analytes of interest
so they represent a good set and a very
well
characterized southbounds that allows us
to develop both reference ranges that
are consistent and measurable against
clinical samples and then also apply
them to different studies and so we
don't want to just sit with amino acids
we will expand it to other ones but as
we do the validation it's a good
starting point for that that aspect dr.
Garrett it looks like we have time for
one more question and your tryptophan
study you showed a cake pathway with
some key edible lights highlighted does
your approach detect all the tryptophan
metabolites that's a good question and
no is the answer because some of them
are below the limits of detection and
and as well as some of them are sitting
in a noisier area depending on their
mass resolution and so we're looking at
ways in which we might be able to
decipher more of the tryptophan pathway
via and use this study as a way to do
that because it represents a very unique
way to validate a metabolic response by
in Crete well or a very common way to
validate a metabolic response because
you want to increase a key nutrient and
by doing that you should be able to
highlight the entire pathway and know
whether or not you're measuring
everything within that path and so one
of our goals with this study is to go
back and look at limits of detection for
other key compounds and how we might
have to concentrate in the sample or do
different sample preparation in order to
highlight different components of the
metabolic pathway or tryptophan and
hopefully in the next few months I'll be
able to show you how that would work
thank you again dr. Garry do you have
any final comments for our audience the
only final coming out have is I hope
that I've showed you that using high
resolution quantitation is possible and
that you may in your next experiment
take the opportunity to try it and see
how well your method could work in that
setting before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
just a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the
the registration we would like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor agilent for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through november of 2018 laboratory via
email when it's available for me by Kurt
Jeff a mail with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye